this is a production of cornell
university
hello everybody i'm delighted to be here
virtually if not in person and thank you
very much from northeast isa
for my invitation to present some
information i think will be interesting
for you
uh this is a work that myself and peter
trowbridge
have done and peter's not gonna be uh
presenting today with me
but it's both of our work that we did at
cornell university for
for many many years so let's get into
the creating the sustainable urban
landscape talk and now
we can take questions after
so uh when we're talking about
sustainable urban landscapes we first
have to recognize
the challenges of the urban environment
of what we're trying to place
in a very challenging environment which
was not built for trees
trees or any kind of plants were an
afterthought to the buildings the roads
the sidewalks
and uh to actually get plants into this
landscape has been
quite challenging also the
urban soils are a critical aspect and
here you see a kind of picture that
tells it all uh here's this big
ball of a tree going to go into that
little
tree pit and we're going to hope for the
best and unfortunately that doesn't
actually
work very well in these very urbanized
areas
so uh how do we define in fact
sustainable
a lot of people have different ideas
about this but
from my point of view i think it's
basically when you
have a sustainable landscape you have
ecosystem services
that are being preserved and enhanced
ecosystem services that are provided by
the urban landscape
and that's plants and soil that can
create sustainable cities
so and we talk about ecosystem services
as services that the plants in the soil
provide for the environment for people
which is storm water reduction
air and water quality improvement
energy conservation as buildings are
shaded by trees and
so on carbon sequestration all this
greens material taking up
carbon reducing co2 uh
urban heat island mitigation is the big
one for
uh cities where we have quite a big
increase in temperature in our urban
areas habitat for pollinators animals
and there are many more ecosystem
services i just listed a few that we can
quantify
and more and more we are quantifying
these and providing a
dollar value for these ecosystem
services provided by the urban landscape
so how do we get these i mean it's great
to say we want these but
from my point of view what we've been
working on for many many
decades is how do you get the plants to
live
and thrive and provide these ecosystem
services
so there's a process that i'd
sort of helped me think about this very
complicated
environment and it's what i feel is the
important part
of creating a sustainable landscape is
the establishment process in other words
getting the plants and soils
in a situation where the plants are
going to thrive so it starts with
site assessment what are you dealing
with what kinds of conditions are you
having to face urban environments are
very heterogeneous
they don't all look the same they have
very different kinds of conditions so we
need to understand
the environment that we're going to be
planting and then
there's a kind of dual step of
once you understand your site you want
to choose the plants that are
adapted for those site conditions and
in many instances our sites are so
limited we have to modify the sites and
that's we're really talking about soils
so that we can actually get plants to to
thrive
and then finally in this landscape
establishment process there's
transplanting
uh techniques and getting the plants uh
off to a good start in the first you
know one to three years
that's the process and now the plants
are going to if you've done it right
they're going to do well they're going
to provide the ecosystem services
and that's what we can do that we can
have the most influence when we do this
landscape establishment process
well so let's just talk about some of
those things
so by the way when we say urban we're
not necessarily
downtown anywhere this is actually a
well-known campus in upstate new york
otherwise known as cornell and this was
the uh
renovation of a library and you can see
the quad
where there's all this you know
machinery and
uh places to
work in and all this destruction and in
the quad
in the aid of uh redoing this library
there so
for three years this building site was
there on the cornell campus
that's what i consider urban as much as
a downtown
area would be it's where there's been a
huge human
impact on the landscape mostly due to
construction
uh or building of new uh
roads and buildings so when you have
this condition it's as much urban as it
would be downtown new york city
and even small cities where there's
there's going to be
utility work or some kind of uh
small process the destruction to the
soil and
perhaps damage to the plants can be
significant
i want to point out here you can see
this little orange snow fence around the
tree
that's supposed to be tree protection
well
that's not true protection of course
it's just somehow trying to keep
maybe trucks away from the trunk of the
tree but we know what's happening in the
foreground
where the soil has been uh dug out and
compacted and all kinds of uh damage and
materials put into the soil that's where
the real is occurring
so all this kind of construction
activity even though it's maybe brief
or could be long has a tremendous impact
on the plant in the soil
so the site assessment issue is
understanding site opportunities and
limitations i mean what is
what are we going to deal with in fact
what you see in the background
here is a building site where there was
a new housing development put in
and this was the staging area what we're
seeing
and after the machinery and the
materials were taken away this is what
was left
and uh the building developer said to
the city of ithaca i said well here you
can make this into a park we're going to
give this
this area and uh
it was quite challenging to understand
what has happened here how can we plant
plants
how can we renovate remediate the soil
so that it will be
supporting plants
so another thing we do in terms of site
assessment we understand to understand
where the trees that exist are and where
are the roots
i think we've all seen some of these you
know
green strips or tree lawns or hell
strips or whatever you call them
with some big trees and when you think
well how is that possible
that those trees are surviving
in such a small soil volume
and solar bond is going to come up a lot
a lot a lot more in terms of what we
need to do
but we did some work with the using uh
air excavation tool
uh to see where the roots were and
what's going on they can't all be
just in those green strips that are
going to allow them to get to that size
you can see some pretty big trees there
so after we uncovered the roots we
painted them white
so you can see just where the roots were
and of course
the roots weren't in those green strips
or they might be somewhat but they're
actually under the sidewalk
and they went into somebody's front yard
or backyard or
churchyard or green leftover area and
that's where the
groups are getting what they need in
terms of the water nutrients oxygen
uh appropriate temperatures and so on
the basics
that plants need and you can also see by
this picture that the roots are
they're just under that four inches of
concrete that we took off i mean they're
not
down deep uh roots
typically don't go more than maybe 18
inches or three
feet max in the best of soils but in
urban soils where it's coming compacted
to
before we lay our pavement you can see
from the gravel there
and compacted the roots cannot actually
access that soil
so they find an area of weakness between
the
concrete and the base course and they
can make their way through there
and into somebody's front yard they can
get a lot more water
and nutrients and so on that they need
so the roots are really at the surface
and most of the urban conditions we see
and of course that causes problems too
because we end up
having roots uh heaving sidewalks and
causing unstable work walking conditions
and then
the outcome of that is often the demise
of the tree as the roots are
cut so roots where the roots are and
what's going on
is an important part of site assessment
that might be underground conditions but
above ground we've got
the old urban heat island and this is
going to be quite
substantial even more so in a hotter
drier summer as we're having now that
the maybe surrounding temperatures might
be
a reasonable temperature but we might
get 10 or
15 degrees hotter in the commercial
residential
area i'll show you something that's i
always like to look at this picture
this is a picture taken with an infrared
camera it's a camera that measures the
surface heat
and so what we're looking at uh
is that dark well you first on the right
hand side you'll see a scale of
temperature and fahrenheit from
67 cool blue to 105
is the kind of hot orange and what we're
looking at is a park
and you can see some tree trunks there
and
under the shade of those trees you have
grass that's pretty
cool about 67 degrees when you come out
from the shade into the grass
surrounding that
you're getting into about 82 degrees
into that green
and blue grass and so you know quite a
bit warmer
and if you come right to the foreground
where you see the orange of course
if you were all in the audience i would
say what is that and you would tell me
oh it's sidewalk and you'll be right
so the sidewalk whether it's asphalt or
concrete
really can increase the temperature or
parked cars
all these built materials can increase
the temperature that that what in
aggregate causes the urban
heat island
so okay that was a really brief uh
view of site assessment both underground
and above ground
issues but when we want to deal with
doing our best for creating a
sustainable landscape we have to think
of two
things really from a point of view of
plants let me talk about plants for a
bit
first the first is trying to find a
plant that it's going to adapt to your
site conditions
or change the site uh to make it better
for the plants
so when you think about plant selection
we're thinking about the genetic
potential of a tree and on the uh
upper left hand of this slide you'll see
a very large tree it's a
london plane tree and there's that
little
uh sort of thing at the bottom it's
actually me
with a stroller my daughter and uh that
tree
you know you could maybe six of us could
put our arms around at the circumference
it was so large it was
showing its true genetic potential in an
environment where it could grow to that
and
genetic potential is all organisms have
genetic potential
we only grow to a certain height we have
certain color hair and so on
but the genetic potential of the tree is
such that
given the best of all resources it will
grow to a certain
size but uh where where
what this tree is up against is the
environment so
just as if we were as people we were
malnourished we wouldn't grow as tall we
wouldn't look as good
and in terms of the tree you see on the
bottom right
that tree is the same genetic material
as the tree on the left
but it's in a different environment so
that environment is
much more limiting in terms of allowing
that tree to grow
so we can think of the genetic potential
as the nature the genetic material
of the plant and what it could grow to
and the environmental reality is the
nurture how much is that environment
allowing the tree to get to its true
genetic potential and sort of matching
those things up
is an important uh process in the plant
selection part of this
so i'm going to go through this slightly
complicated
uh slide to show you some things that we
look at
in terms of choosing plants for
difficult conditions so a lot of what
we're dealing with in urban environments
is a limited water availability not so
much that it might be for instance there
might be plenty of water
in the growing season in your area but
the way that
trees are planted in urban environments
their water often doesn't get to the
root system so you have a limited
water availability and there are
adaptations that plants
use to deal with this
one is an avoidance so we avoid water
deficits by
let's say maximizing water acquisition
by having a really large root system
deep rooting increased water uptake
um or we could avoid water deficits by
closing the stomates the pores and the
leaf which
bring in carbon dioxide and
take release oxygen and also release
water if
if the water is not getting out of the
leaf it's kind of being
constricted but also puts the model
closure which is a
mechanism to reduce water loss you're
also reducing the ability
for plants to grow because no carbon
dioxide no
um carbon dioxide is getting into
the leaf and so um
we can also reduce have a smaller tree
that's also another
basically an idea of avoidance but in
the urban environment we really want
those plants that can tolerate so don't
have to go through
avoidance mechanisms but we want
tolerators those that
can take it basically take a droughty
hot season and still basically
photosynthesize
and are taking it
to be able to be functional so this is
uh something we're working on is to
find out those trees that have a
tolerance of water deficit
by adjusting what's in their cells so
that they don't actually
lose turgor or they don't wilk
and so this is a much more difficult
thing and
for trees to do but we've actually been
testing this and i'll just
show you a little bit about some of the
work we've been doing on this
so um so this is uh i just want to say
about uh
avoidance like having a big root system
well that does their urban environment
often precludes
the ability for roots to actually extend
a long area and go deep because of
you can see here this parking lot with
this tree just went over because
it only had about four to six inches of
usable soil so the roots just stayed
where they were and they had
very little space to actually explore a
larger volume of soil
so that idea of these trees avoiding it
it's just not going to work where you
have restricted soil
this is another avoidance mechanism
here's a silver linden the
tiliatomantosa beautiful tree
and if you look really carefully on the
undersides of this
leaf which is fairly white hence the
name silver linden
you'll see these kind of trichomes or
hair like
or amoeba-like structures on the
side of the leaf you can also see the
the pores there where so the stomates
which
where water is lost and carbon dioxide
come in
and those trichomes or amiibo-like
structures are actually
shading and covering some of the
stomates so water
loss is reduced so that's an avoidance
mechanism
it's kind of neat i love this picture
but it's telling you why you have
white on the undersides of silver linden
but uh a tolerator
is a tree that can manage
trigger loss without uh we
actually can manage drought without
losing terror and it can be a universal
measure
of physiological drought and it's
quantifiable
and measurable and we can rank species
in terms of their
physiological drought tolerance in other
words they're not
trying to close their stomachs they're
just sitting there with their stomachs
open
but really tolerating that drought
so we about 20 years ago we started
looking at
oaks in terms of their their naturally
fairly drought tolerant
and they have some issues that we wanted
to deal with
and we had had some breeding in
2004-2006
in the white oak group we had seven
maternal
parents white oaks on the cornell campus
and we've got
36 pollen parents um
paternal parents from all over the
country and somewhere all over the world
and we ended up with 350 unique
genotypes unique types of hybrid oaks
which we started growing and the first
thing we had to know
these all of these trees were unique
genotypes
because they had even if they had same
parents and
mother and father each kid each acorn
was different
so just like parents give rise to
different children you could have the
same cross but
different um children or acorns in this
case
so we uh uh we grew these for a long
time and then we actually
started to we needed to be able to help
to propagate them if we would
to capture the coral nature of these
unique hybrids but one of the things we
did
before we did that was to test
some of these oaks for their ability to
tolerate
water of drought and on the left you see
two um
oaks in the white oak family and the one
on the far left is well watered
in the container just well water all
season and the one on the
just right to that uh oh it's been
sequentially
uh experiencing drought so it would
water it and then we'd let it dry down
for a week or more when we water it
again
and then light let it dry down for
another two weeks in water again so it
had sequential drought
and they still look pretty good i mean
they are
in terms of what the one on the just
right of that
far left looks like on the other hand
look at the
right hand panel and you see this is not
oaks these
are birds the birds are not particularly
known to be drought
resistant the one on the far right is
well watered and you can see it's
growing fine
the one just uh to the left of that
had had that sequential drought uh
cycles and it and it's
its mechanism to deal with that it just
drops its leaves it just
says i'm i'm bored you know i'm getting
rid of all these leaves which are losing
water
and i'll hopefully wait for a better
time or if all the leaves drop
the tree might die you can see the
difference between
the avoider on the right which is
dropping its leaves to reduce
water loss and the tolerator on the left
the oak
which is able to continue to grow to
keep its stomates open
to photosynthesize even in the face
of sequential drought so this is what
we're looking for those
tolerator type plants
and just to show you one graph uh here
we can see
uh on the top this these bars are
showing
the amount of trigger loss so
the the lower let's say we see minus
2.5 minus 3 minus 3.5 on the x-axis
the more negative the
trigger loss point is means the more
that tree is able to tolerate
a really droughty condition so on the
bottom
three bars you'll see those which were
well watered and they didn't really
change
much from spring to late summer
they were all well watered but the ones
on the top three bars
were those in that sequential drought so
in the spring
it wasn't really drought stress at all
mid-summer
uh just started to get you know still a
bit of a drought stress
but in late summer where i had
experienced a lot of drought stress
was able to step it up if you like and
reduce its turbo loss point to beyond
what would be normal for that
well-watered tree so it's able to
actually respond
to a dry environment and create a more
a tolerated type mechanism
so we then had to actually propagate
these
plants so you can capture the clonal
nature of some of these really excellent
hybrids that we created of course they
were not all of them were not great but
some of them were really good maybe out
of 350 maybe
i'd say 15 to 20 were really worth
um working with and so to propagate oaks
typically it's their oaks are propagated
by acorns which then you lose the
clonal nature of those hybrids so we we
did this
mechanism where we actually cut back the
trees
and as the buds were breaking on the
stem we edulate them cover them with a
pot and a brick so it wouldn't fall off
and then those
mediolated or shoots that grow in the
dark
would form and we paint and those
mediated shoots which had not seen the
light
are very much more sensitive to high
auxins and rooting hormones and they
actually do
are able to root as uh cuttings
we then paint the bases of those shoots
with a rooting hormone
and then cover it with a little shade so
that they can acclimate to full light
and then we take off the shade you can
see those shoots coming up
through a growing meeting which we put
in those uh
cans if you like and then by the end of
the season we have
shoots that have plenty of roots on them
from that
original one plant and these are clones
so
you can see on the far right bottom
these are shoots that we took off of
that one
tree and these are clones of that plant
and of course this is a quite a
painstaking thing but we've been able to
get clonal
material and we're working on other
methods now of actually increasing that
propagation which is what you see here
on the far right is we're going to
tissue culture where
we're actually clonally propagating
these oaks
and we're actually able to really
multiply them much faster than
the method i just showed you and that's
one of our hybrids it's a
it's a quite a complex hybrid of uh
uh baroque and gamba lok with um
over cup oak and it's here in ithaca and
it's
growing in uh just in lawn area and it's
one of the things where one of the
plants were
first going to be introducing to the
nursery trade
uh once we get enough of them and this
one is particularly drought tolerant it
can have a very low
trigger loss point so it's able to
tolerate drought
and not lose trigger or lose leaves
on here and then we gave all of these we
had a whole bunch of these
oaks that we were had propagated to a
pretty large
size and we gave them away to
communities in new york state and uh
they were there in a long-term
evaluation process now and you can see
the
happy people with their hybrid
in oak first year of planting
so just in terms of plant selection um
i've thought a lot about this and there
are basic tenets
to what we should be selecting for
plants
that uh will deal well with urban
environments first
we need pest resistant plants adapted to
site conditions
and we know there are some trees that
say who are more or less pests pest
tolerant and we can be choosing those
you don't want to have to
deal with pests insects or diseases that
can decimate the plants so we can look
for plants that are adapted to site
conditions
both in terms of the environmental
conditions
we want non-invasive but highly diverse
plantings so
the idea of having monocultures or too
many of one plant can give
can provide food for any particular
insect or disease that comes down
the street and they always do come down
the street and in new england we've
studied the
diversity of urban tree populations and
we've studied
new york pennsylvania new jersey
massachusetts
connecticut and we find that the
propensity
of street trees are i would ask you this
if we are
looking at you but you would tell me
they're all maples
most of the trees of the northeast
united states
street trees are maples you know
somewhere between
uh 30 and 50 percent not just one
species of maple but several species of
maple and that's
you know as they're great trees i love
maples but we have to have a diversity
if we're going to have
a hedge against any kind of insect or
disease that might be
brought into this uh this part of the
country
and this is by the way the whole issue
of one or a few trees being
the most numerous is something that
happens all over the world
in europe and asia uh africa south
america
it's typically a very non-diverse street
tree population and we need to
diversify and there are resources to
help you
look for plants that you may not be
familiar with
that are will do very well in your sites
so non-invasive but very highly diverse
and it has to meet the design of
functional objectives of the site
you want shade you want to screen what
is the objective
of the site
and fourth is managing management
limitations
you have to print it a lot you have the
front the manpower to do that
um so these are basic tenants of plant
selection criteria and i think it's
something to think about
when you're going to plant trees is to
think about diversity
adaptation and design functional
objectives
so uh if we can choose the right plants
and that's a really important part i
mean to choose
good plants that will tolerate side
conditions
well well we often get into a situation
where we've just
done construction and we're going to put
back the landscape or
then we can see what we we have on this
site the soil has been regraded it's
been mounted up we've have compaction
of the soil with machinery and then
we're going to kind of heal it over with
a few inches of
topsoil maybe and put some grass on it
and inevitably
the trees start to decline because they
have to accept all this kind of
devastation and here's that place in
cornell campus again that i showed you
before i'd like to show you some of the
processes we've used to remediate
compacted and
just trashed soils
this is the same now it's the
construction has been finished on the
library and they've been pulling out the
machines and trucks and you can see
uh just looking at the surface what the
soil was like
right in the front of that that library
so this is the good stuff this is what
we recognize as horticulturalists and as
arborists and that is the good stuff it
has
in the technical term it has clumps and
spaces
that's not the technical term but i'm
going to use it here clumps are
soils that are clumped together to
provide water holding a nutrient holding
and spaces which allow water to drain
through an oxygen to come in
but in urban environments we often get
this kind of
soil which has been compacted
in the course of construction to bear
load
and to not be subsiding and this kind of
soil
uh has two major factors one water
doesn't drain through it so it may sit
on top of that layer
and then the soil is so dense
that roots cannot penetrate it so it
might
soil might as well not be there if roots
can't get into it
from the plant's point of view
and i would say here that soil is more
important than trees when you're dealing
with an urban landscape
you can see a parking island here and
the
perfectly good red oak in the parking
island
is just seeming to die back and looking
poorly
and i had the opportunity to when they
were doing some work
in this parking lot to look at that
island that you see
and look what happened after rainfall
there's no drainage
it did not drain at all because the soil
underneath
that island was compacted when they
built the parking lot
so you have a bathtub and when you have
a bathtub
there's two things you can do you can
choose plants that tolerate
standing water and there are some and
you don't want to choose a red oak which
cannot tolerate
standing water and needs a well-draining
soil
so you can make
use plant selection to be some part of
the
solution but also you can change the
soil and make it more amenable
to a large number of plants
so one process we've been working on for
many years is what's called the scoop
and dump method
now this is a way to remediate compacted
soil
uh using a lot of compost
and with a deep uh
come on uh incorporation into the
compacted soil so what we do
basically is apply at least six
inches of compost so that's just sitting
on top
not not talking about mulching or
anything like that this is about six
inches of
good compost on top of a compacted soil
we use a backhoe bucket to dig down to
about 18 inches
combining the soil and compost through
creating veins of compost through the
compacted soil of the clogs
we then after we do that we then plant
the mulch with two to three inches of
shredded bark or other
organic mulch material and we re-mulch
yearly to maintain two to three inches
of surface layer
mulch until we have canopy closure
so we do this and we've done this now
for
15 years and i will see where we are
we're up and so that is that
the same front of the library after we
remediated and planted it
and then this is a couple of years later
so
uh it's done very very well it was
totally compacted
we did this scoop and dump meth and we
were able to really
achieve a really sustainable
landscape what i meant by the way was
canopy closure which is when we
want to have the shrubs of the trees
touching each other so we don't have a
lot of bare soil
between that and generally when we plant
it takes oh
one to three years before we get canopy
closure if we're planting in the right
spacing because when we have canopy
closure we have very low
weed issues to deal with the plants
actually shade the ground and retain
some moisture and we get a much
better effect so i'm going to
hopefully start a little video for you
that describes this method
this is a production of cornell
university
whoops let's go back
try again sorry okay
this is a production of cornell
university
so this is a scoop and dump method that
we used with our students doing the work
no nothing less you know better than
having 40 students doing some work for
you
here we are applying compost
to a really compacted uh
soil area next to the parking lot
oh yeah it seems good it seems pretty
deep
and we're applying humble to the whole
thing
[Music]
and then we come in with a backhoe and
we're digging down about
18 inches
notice this yellow flash around the
existing trees
you don't want to get too close and then
we're going to damage those trees
[Music]
and then we plant we don't throw the
till or smooth it out
we're just basically planting plants
that will tolerate this
uh if there's a swale next to a parking
lot so water is going to come in from
the parking lot through this fire soil
i'll show you that's a little time lapse
on what's going on here this is when we
visited
in uh april of 2014
doing the planting and then we mulched
the entire thing
get a injection of compost through the
soil and we plant and then we mulch
two to three inches of shredded bar
and this is uh you know this is early
may of 2014 this is what it looked like
after we were doing three
three bios walls that were connected
next to this parking lot
so we're hopeful now a four months later
here we are september
things are going really well i mean when
you provide
soil volume usable soil for plants
they respond okay not just a hole
but creating a site where plants can
really
utilize that solar vine they really
respond
this is four months later after you
planted
they're doing okay here's the water
coming into the
soils and being distributed now
next summer the summer since 2015
we're getting quite a lot of growth
things have really moved on
from that initial year we're not a quiet
canopy closure but we're close
and it has to be you have to understand
how to space plants so that you are
going to get kind of exposure you can't
put them too far apart
have a really diverse planting catalog
those that can tolerate
really wet soils and those that are on
the sides
and just two years later uh
and now we're really at canopy closure
with is totally closed in
we have very little weed pressure except
on the edges where we
meet the asphalt here that's the paint
throughout so that's really the weed
pressure we have
but here i'm standing next to these
bioscales and they're really
uh filling in very very well
so we have a tremendously diverse
palette
and we also have no dumping in this in
the winter
and the water but it's
showing you it's not an impossible
process
so the scoop and dump method uh shows
that we we gain soil resistance
decreasing but basically the compaction
is decreased
we get more poor volume which means
drainage is increased
and we we have a reduction in bulk
density which basically
means that the density of the soil is
decreased so
we have better root penetration we
increase in carbon and nitrogen improve
soil structure
uh increase aggregate stability that's
that those crumps when i show you the
picture of the
soil with clumps and spaces the
aggregates or the crumbs
are become stable and actually
increasing porosity
you get improved plant growth and
long-term improvement of soil conditions
and plant growth we've done this this
particular uh
bioswell is 13 years old and it's doing
exceptionally well
and one of the things that people often
ask is well what if you put so much
you know six inches of compost into 18
inches of soil that's a lot of compost
and isn't it going
to basically be eaten and go away and
it's true
so what we do is adding this the
mulch on top is critical because the
mulch
gets hot well let's step back a minute
with
the increase of compost we're actually
increasing the micro
uh biome the micro organisms in the soil
they do the heavy lifting okay so the
microorganisms are going to be
creating structure also utilizing the
mulch on top
and increasing the organic matter in the
soil so we're not
losing organic matter as long as we
mulch and the microorganisms then
bring that organic matter down into the
root zone
so we do the motion at least till we get
canopy closure
uh and sometimes even after but canopy
closure gives you
leaves fall and create their own mulch
and we're not going to be losing organic
matter
and have subsidence which is something
we don't want to have
so we found that over time we actually
inc
over 13 years or so in this process
i thought well i thought well things
would actually get
worse after time but in fact they get
better
the bulk density or the density of the
soil actually decreases over time
because we're increasing the organic
matter in the soil
and the structure of the soil is being
improved by the microorganisms
so that was a no surprise to me when we
did the data
is that we're actually reducing the
density over time
and we also get lots more benefits in
terms of
the different factors that happen to the
soil and all this
improvement of soil health and soil
structure provides
a great medium to grow cleansing
so one more thing i wanted to show you
was uh
when we have purposeful compaction so
what i showed you before is inadvertent
compaction due to construction we're not
trying to combat the soil but
of course it was compacted due to
construction
when we're laying pavement we have to
purposely compact the soil so that
the pavement is not going to subside or
fail
and that needs another
technique to deal with that so here we
have a sidewalk we have
right in the foreground you can see that
square of wood that's going to be
paved with concrete and what's going to
go into that square i would ask you if i
saw you in person
of course the tree is going to go into
that square and then you know you see
reinforcement and the
concrete is going to be laid and the
tree is going to go in that square now
the soil in that
around the square has been compacted
and a base course put on it and so it's
been treated
no differently in the square than it is
in the surrounding
reinforcement area and that's a problem
because tree roots just cannot
get out of those
restricted areas here you see i told a
tree
bulb being placed into the coffin and
roots really can't
escape more uh unless they heave the
sidewalk and get out of that
area but they are often restricted in
these small spaces
so we uh we decided to develop something
called
cu structural soil which was to use that
area under the sidewalk
as so a lower bearing surface
but still could allow trees to get
through it
and this is the idea of it basically we
have crushed stone about one and a half
inches and that's the angular particles
you see here
and because they're basically all one
size about one and a half inches
when they touch each other they create
big core spaces in between and that's
where our soil
and our oxygen you know water movement
comes from so
we have a rigid gravel uh lattice of
elon ore
and then soil in the pores where roots
can just shoot through those pores
because the soil between the gravel
is not compacted here's what it looks
like
you can use different types stone wood
depending where you are
we happen to have our cheap stone here
in western new york is
limestone and that has implications for
plant selection
that's what it looks like when it's
mixed with soil
there's a little bit of hydrogel we add
to so we don't get separation of soil
and particle stone and then it looks
pretty
you know pretty stoney pretty droughty
but when it gets compacted it forms this
lattice or rigid structure which can be
load bearing for pavement
and still allow roots to go through it
we did some testing we planted some i
built some sidewalks of nowhere and uh
had some structural soil
separations here we have some all
chronal uh
isoplanoids here growing after several
years
and we decided to take it apart and see
what was going on
so we took up the concrete and
we had controls where we compacted it as
a normal sidewalk and then we had
the structural soil in these trenches
and when we got this is a structural
soil root zone
we uncovered the entire thing using uh
air excavation tool in these three foot
deep trenches
which were restricted on the sides
you can see that very fibrous root zone
it's almost a kinked nature as the roots
go through the stone lattice
and this is a control you can see the
compacted soil and then a little bit of
face course and where we planted the
tree there and we also excavated that
which was much easier
and that was the uh typical
root zone of a tree in a compacted soil
the roots on the side sort of made it
down the side of the trench which we had
compacted and makes them
didn't escape but basically we did a
pancake root system
and we we wanted to actually look at the
if we can
measure the roots remotely without
having to take it all apart like we just
did
using a ground penetrating radar and
here you see the super
tricycle which has the radar machine it
would go over concrete or soil or
whatever and it will
show us we'll have a reflection back
where the roofs are
in the soil
we tested it in this sidewalks of
nowhere to
make sure we were getting good agreement
between what the radar was saying and
what we actually saw we took the trees
apart so
this was giving us confidence that we
could use this to locate roots in other
areas as well so this is a kind of
uh detail or cross-section of what we
would how we would plant
trees and structural soil in a sidewalk
uh
we always in the opening with the tree
is we always put good
soil we don't want to put structural
soil in the
tree ball tree opening itself we only
put it under the pavement
we want to maximize water and nutrients
in the tree
uh ball planting area because because
structural soil is good it does it what
it does does what it's supposed to do
it is not particularly good in terms of
water holding capacity so we want to
maximize that
we've done a lot of planting i have a
lot of experience now with this here you
see uh in brooklyn
new york we had baseball elms and
calorie pears
after three years well and then after
12 years and see how they're growing the
on the top left you see tree pits with
structural soil in fact that's not
the tree that structural cause soil goes
through a trench from
tree pits or tree pits so it's not just
in the opening you see there
and this is in the homestead elms
in ithaca new york after eight years
growth in structural soil this was in
the olympic site
using structural soil for these oriental
planes
uh miami beach palms and structural soil
uh and doing very well even uh very high
windy conditions
one thing about the wind because this
the roots get out so far
they have the trees are able to stand up
as opposed to roots being in a
restricted box where they tend to go
over
in a windy situation
and we started looking at this from a
point of view of ecosystem services and
trying to reduce the problems of
flooding
so traditional development can you you
can have flooding events which is
this is actually a highway not too far
from us
where we had a big rain event and you
just get a lot of flooding
so how can we use structural soil and uh
to actually
increase this or deal with this
situation
so structural soils allow porous asphalt
and structural soil
was the was the thing we wanted to try
we actually
wanted to filter water through the
pavement slowly recharging the
groundwater
reducing the need for retention
detention ponds and biosoils that allows
trees to grow
in the pave sites if we had structural
soil and porous asphalt
wouldn't just be you know covering two
problems with one solution so the reason
why we could do this
is that uh look at soil alone you'll see
when you compact the soil to proctor
density which is a standard
compaction effort we get about 34
percent
just soil alone 30 porosity but
on the lower part you see 2.2 and that
was the macro force
the macropore is only two percent which
allow water and air to move through it
on the structural soil side uh you have
26 percent
total porosity compacted to 100 proctor
density
but we have 31 of that is the macropores
which allows water to
move through it quickly and the
infiltration rate is greater than 24
inches an hour in structural soil
was less than a half an inch and typical
compacted soil
so knowing this we could actually put a
system together
this was a little uh parking area that
near a trail head and the city of if we
wanted to
make this a better better construction
so we decided
to use structural soil and porous
asphalt to
see if we can make this work so here's
the structural soil
being put into the
that whole parking area it was like it's
like 24 to 30 inches deep
compacted and then we put traditional
asphalt on one side of it
and the porous asphalt on the other side
of it you can see in a rain
what that looks like the rain goes right
through the porous and
does not go through the traditional
asphalt we then saw cut
oh there's you can see porous on the
right hand side and
non-porous asphalt on the left side
we saw cut into it and we planted uh
accolade elms into the structural soil
and then i put big yellow barriers next
to the trees so that
no snowplow would take them out in the
winter
yes a little bit over designed from the
point of view of those barriers but
those were little one and a half inch
caliper trees
and i was one of them to stay there for
a long time
so that was the first year after
planting
and this is about uh four years later
and this was 2012 and this was
2019.
so they've grown really really well and
uh
we wanted to look at some what was
happening with the porous asphalt
group and the non-tourist asphalt group
so at the pores on the right you can
start to see that they're
a little bit bigger than the non-porous
asphalt group
again all the structural soil but the
non-porous asphalt group they're
starting to get
not growing quite as well as the ones in
the porous asphalt
so come back with our ground penetrating
radar the city wouldn't like us to take
this all apart
after they built this whole parking lot
so we uh
we actually scanned the root zones of
the porous and non-porous asphalt
and to see what we were actually seeing
on the ground
so here you see this three tree three
and four
were planted in non-porous asphalt
all the structural soil and trees eight
and nine were in porous asphalt
with structural soil that's the layout
and we had trees also sing part portion
part uh porous and non-porous but i'll
just talk about three four and eight and
nine
so this is a slice this is what kind of
data you can get
each pass with the ground penetrating
radar gives you a slice and all those
red dots
are roots that they grow go
they pick up from the radar and you can
also see the depth so
from anywhere from you know five inches
down to
about 25 inches down we're getting some
roots we'll seeing roots between on both
sides those trees
and you know this was good we're getting
roots down
but i like this and this was in the
non-porous
vlog okay non-porous asphalt and we were
so what what
what do we find in the porous asphalt
that's what we found in the porous
asphalt
ground penetrating each slice is a
slice of radar and the roots go way down
up to
30 32 inches deep many more roots
in the porous asphalt versus the
non-porous asphalt
this is another way of looking at that
data where we have a color coded
if we mash all the roots the surface and
look at density root density
the cooler blue or green colors means
fewer roots and the hotter orange and
brown colors means more roots
that's what it looked like in the
non-porous asphalt
and this is what it looks like in the
porous asphalt so many more roots
much deeper and just another way of
visually looking at
what the root growth was in those trees
and if we look at just all together
we're getting
more roots in the surface first zero to
eight inches
and about the same amount of roots uh
porous and non-porous asphalt
in the middle but where we're really
getting more roots is in the deeper
greater than 16 inch
profile many more roots in the
uh horus asphalt planting
so i just give live here some thought
because this was a
you were seeing a couple of just uh
something to think about when you're
planting and this happens to be in
porous and in structural soil
but there's virtually only 18 by 18
inches
and available to get water into the
ground so we need to think about
water infiltration when we deal a soil
and paving it has to have infiltration
whether it's concrete block or porous
asphalt
or many different types of porous
materials
you have to get roots watered down to
the roots to make this work
so this is my last slide to just uh i
wanted to i mentioned
you need resources to be able to find
and look for
better trees and new soil techniques and
a whole bunch of
other things that are there trees
protecting trees during construction
so this is my website and i really wish
that you go
visit it and you can there's a numerous
things that you can see
there there's videos there's all kinds
of free materials that you can download
and there's also something called the
woody plant database which
if you look at that there are over 400
woody plants that are rated for
different types of environmental
conditions
and lots of pictures so it's a website
full of information
uh and i really hope that you all use it
by the way the picture you're seeing
there is a ducati park in
manhattan and all those honeymookers are
in structural soil
so we like to see our work go out to
where it's really going to be useful
and by doing things at the beginning
well doing that
plant establishment process well we end
up with much more sustainable
urban forests and urban conditions so i
thank you for your
attention i wish we could have been
there in person but
we'll leave it at that
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu